we don't do this often but I will reveal
that today is Halloween tonight is
Halloween and this is going to be uh do
you if a child is less than two do they
they don't care about Halloween do they
no he does not care about how he doesn't
understand it but he
um we try to put a costume on him and he
ref he he knew somehow that he doesn't
want to wear anything on his head did
your kid like they don't want to wear
anything on their heads they don't have
to put that you know there has to be
some sort of elastic keeping it on but
don't they don't have a choice yeah but
then they my kid is ripping it off so
that I knew we wanted he he likes he's
limited interest frankly
he likes blueberries
um so I was like I'm limited that's
specific yeah Focus he loves him yeah he
probably just loves any antioxidant he
loves antioxidants he's a health nut
yeah he's an absolute I'm told that was
my first word yeah
true because I I worried about cancerous
cells as a young child in the early 60s
that's also me that's me very young it's
also me very old as a very old woman
which is happening slowly or no I'm
transitioning I'm getting older and
transitioning at the same time what a
dream yeah I would I will happily come
back on the podcast at that point I'd
love to be a cruel old woman someday
you're getting there
right I'm getting there virtually there
yeah yeah I just want to like pure I
want to part my curtains in peer
suspiciously out the window of my
Victorian Mansion yes at any at young
couples just doing completely normal
things and go hmm we'll see about that
and then call the police that's that's
what I really dream of calling the
police regularly calling the police as
an old a really old Karen an old lady
Karen I just like you in a big bed yeah
I'm in a giant bed and I have a
long-suffering Butler who takes care of
me
did you see any youngsters outside this
morning we will have the dogs out upon
them
you have a hard candy I could suck up
what are you talking about yeah this is
what it's all about
the only thing that calms me when I'm an
old woman is a hard butterscotch suck on
you can't even take the plastic off of
it so melt it in yeah come on he's
eating the plastic yeah but I call it
the skin
what are you wearing in this bed no oh
I'm wearing a tattered old wedding dress
sham Dickens wedding dress
because she didn't show on the day and
then a Clipper's a hat
yeah put regularly to the side now I'm
going to rap so y'all
my name is Conan and I'm here to say no
not that 80s rap please this is
Halloween where did this go why are you
rapping well because
she put a Lakers hat on me yeah and then
I mean a Clipper's hat and then it went
on Sideways and then where else can you
go then you gotta go to rap okay sorry
you know yeah that's the scariest ghost
story ever
so that was ironically so that's what my
kids Halloween costume ended up being
yeah
oh
[Laughter]
look that was why I think it the costume
took a little work to get into it is
funny how you're in that there's this
phase where you're doing things because
it's supposed to be for the kid but
they're they're full computer hasn't
turned on yet so and you you know this
too girly where it's it's you know yay
you're gonna sit on Santa's lap or happy
Hanukkah or thank you by the way I
appreciate it is it channika no it's
Hanukkah you got it right no okay
um and is it Christmas
Christmas Merry Christmas
the Jewish narc trying to pass
that's what you say I love that I love I
love the idea a Jewish
Merry Christmas
another Christian boy
and you're not for your blood and now
you're not sure about the Traditions
you're trying to light the tree we light
all the candles on the tree on no no you
don't do that and we don't control the
media today
coming on are you gonna get
one he's on right after you he's outside
he's ready to come in I was thinking oh
to be responsible I should not buy
Kanye's stuff and then I realized I've
never bought content stuff I would never
wear Kanye stuff you don't want to buy
sweatshirts for the the very depressed
exactly all of his sweatshirts are so
like tattered and big like nobody you
don't wear that and if you're in a good
mood right right
okay you took us there sorry I brought
it down there should have stayed on
Jewish stereotypes in Christmas and was
good but once Kanye comes up it's over
whole mood changing I know it's been
wild but uh but anyway so my kid won't
wear a costume and that's uh so you
normally wouldn't date this as a
Halloween you don't date it you don't
want people to know when this is when
this came when this well I'm looking at
our I'm looking at our producer here
um he's giving a thumbs up yeah and he's
saying it's fine look people we can
acknowledge that uh that things
sometimes I don't know when this is
coming out when's it coming out things
number seven it's just a week yeah later
yeah people are still reeling from
Halloween at this point a week later
still got that Halloween candy out right
you know some of that stuff you can uh
for a couple of months some of that
stuff you can really get keep getting
kids to come to your house okay yeah
okay what do you mean exactly wait a
minute we've got the candy out then kids
keep coming to the house
yeah
what do you mean why
let's not ask why it's good to have kids
around can we get Kanye in here it's a
little more comfortable if when you're
bringing Kanye into light in the mood if
you know you have a problem
I told you once that my my brother
Justin and I were in Boston and uh he
had his kids with him and uh we just
stopped in Boston Common there's a there
was a playground there and I'm leaning
against this chain link fence with my
brother and it's I don't know December
or something and my brother's kids are
playing in the playground and I'm just
hanging out and this guy came by and no
joke just this Boston guy came by and
he's like hey gone and you know he's
like uh hey come on you got a kid in
that playground
and I just said you better [ __ ] hope
so like no I just I just heard there was
a playground here and I wanted to kind
of hang out
but I was like what a weird question
that's just the Boston version of saying
you got a dog in this fight yeah yeah
this playground